yo I'm Luke Cage I ain't no woman you
can't burn me you can't blast me and you
definitely can't break me I ain't no
joke don't test me
step up I'm right here hey black man
everybody it's Charlie get rekt we got
our first Luke Cage season two teasers
they even work in Heroes for our Easter
Egg at the end of that ya get paid get
paid they didn't stick any Danny Rand in
this but I don't think that would have
made it better I think people know that
Iron Fist is going to get start during
season two of Luke Cage and they'll have
some Heroes for Hire action but it's
still primarily luke cage's series if
you're just finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there three Netflix series
dropping this year we have Jessica Jones
Luke Cage season 2 and then daredevil
season 3 dropping later this year
biggest surprise is actually that
they're dropping it so early so they
decided to drop it June 22nd instead of
waiting all the way till August at the
end of the summer like they did with
defenders maybe because they found
people are more willing to binge this
kind of stuff at the beginning of the
summer than the end of the summer our
Netflix has crazy data that they never
released so they could actually tell you
exactly how many people are watching
stuff but they don't release those
statistics so what he's doing in this
actually looks like a call to action
after a big action set piece like
somebody ties him up and puts him in the
back of his truck then blows the truck
up trying to kill him and he just steps
out like it's no big deal like he just
brushes himself off like huh gotta go
find some more clothes now but when he's
speaking in a camera here this actually
feels like they literally just cut it
out of an episode so it's not like he's
addressing us the audience although it
does get kind of meta in that way it
sounds like whoever the villain that
stuck him in here put a camera outside
to monitor him and is just watching him
to make sure that he dies and he steps
out like hell yeah you can't blow me up
you can't shoot me you can't break me
because I'm Luke Cage obviously he's
still in Harlem so you get a couple more
scenes of him just going around taking
out some of these gangs the look on his
face in this scene here in this
warehouse probably comes after this
mometrix in there's probably all these
people in the background circling around
him like they're all gonna take him on
at the same time and he's just getting
ready to throw down throw more people
off of buildings if you don't recognize
the African American College Alliance
clothing brand that was just like a
really big hip-hop brand back in the
early 90s late 80s they were a clothing
brand for a long time but they really
blew up in the early 90s when hip-hop
artists started wearing their brands on
stage so even though they do kind of
identify with
collegiate stuff like actual college
university stuff they're mostly known as
a clothing brand you can actually go buy
their stuff right now today off their
website but part of the idea this
teasers that he's just throwing down now
like he's not holding back he's not
sitting around on the stoop on pops
although there are pictures that they've
released where he's rebuilt pops so it
does exist like he does use it as a
hangout it's just that he's not gonna
spend four or five episodes trying to
decide what he's gonna do with his
powers which is kind of what happened
during season one like he got out of
prison he think couldn't figure out what
to start doing with himself until
cottonmouth turned into more of the real
villain of the series and he's you know
unfortunately he's dead so he's one of
the only characters that's not coming
back but pretty much everybody else from
season one is coming back with the
exception of Diamondback I'm expecting
him back but they're keeping that pretty
close to the vest so they're not saying
officially yes or no because you know
big theory he could probably survive the
same treatment the way that Luke Cage
did because he shares DNA with his
father
[Music]
because part of the idea that experiment
that gave him powers is that he's one of
the only people that was able to live
through that so the idea is that maybe
his brother can - he'll eventually
become a much bigger kingpin style
villain down the road if they can write
him a good arc I felt like his arc
wasn't quite as good as the cottonmouth
arc during Luke Cage season 1 but misty
Nights back she's got her bionic arm
courtesy of Danny rands hospitals we
don't know exactly how many episodes
Iron Fist is going to be starring in I'm
guessing less than half so maybe like
three or four episodes I haven't seen
any of that footage yet just the behind
the scenes stuff of them trying to train
together so he's got the sweet Christmas
shirt so it looks like they really are
going full Heroes for Hire although you
know the funny part of that being that
he's a billionaire so it's not like he
needs any money but I think part of the
idea at the end of defenders is that
he's sort of picking up Daredevils bead
because they all believe that he's dead
so he's like I need to step up and be a
real hero if you're not a big comic book
reader there was a period in the comics
where iron fist wore Daredevils costume
and operated his daredevil in Hell's
Kitchen there was even a period when
Spiderman wore the daredevil costume
there been a lot of people - we're
Daredevils costume besides daredevil but
you have to sort of imagine that since
the supposed death of Matt I mean we
know he's alive but everyone else
believes he's dead he's been running
around rooftops trying to help people
out and he probably gets roped into
whatever it's happening during Luke Cage
season two helps him out for a little
while then he goes back to fill in for
daredevil indefinitely until we see Matt
again during daredevil season 3 speaking
of which if they're dropping Luke Cage
season 2 this early then it's totally
possible we see daredevil season 3
episodes by like September but we
haven't any firm premiere date on that
and they waited this long to announce
Luke Cage season 2 so it wouldn't be
surprised if they wait till comic-con
this year to announce the daredevil
season 3 premiere date but maybe we'll
get some sort of teaser at the end of
Luke Cage season 2 like they've been
doing like Jessica Jones hasn't even
premiered yet and they've already
dropped this Luke Cage teaser the crazy
thing that the actress who plays Jessica
Jones Krysten Ritter just said in an
interview is that she implied that they
might not be doing Defenders season 2
they might just be doing new seasons of
each of the separate characters TV shows
like daredevil season 4 daredevil season
5 Luke Cage season 3
the reason being is that they only
talked about that first season nobody
has raised the question of season two at
least to the actors I think that the
producers and the business people behind
the scenes have definitely talked about
it but just think about that we might
live in a world where there is no more
official defenders team up and
characters just cross over to each other
series like we have Iron Fist crossing
over with Luke Cage during Luke Cage
season two so we might just be seeing a
lot more of that instead of doing more
traditional defenders team ups but no
official word on that yet I'm working a
case yeah how's that going for you so
far
I have back doors clear everything's
locked I think we're safe for now
so we're just gonna wait it out here you
got a better plan is there a plan where
I get my scarf back just need until this
is over what do you two know each other
yeah we met you drank I shot him in the
head but for those of you asking yes
Jessica Jones episodes are dropping
tonight at midnight as I'm posting this
video I will do a review video but
because it's not quite as popular on my
channel I'll probably just do like a
review video for the entire season
that's non spoilery and maybe depending
on interest I'll do separate Easter Egg
videos it's just that of all the Netflix
series Jessica Jones is the least
popular on my channel next to iron fist
people really did not like iron fist so
what will happen is is my non-spoilery
Jessica Jones video will probably post
on Friday because most people won't
watch the series for a couple more days
or even through the entire weekend so
it's gonna be a while so there's not a
real big rush on that but we actually
found out that Mark Hamill might be
starring on The Witcher TV series he
might also be starring in guardians of
the galaxy 3 so we'll try to get all
those videos out as fast as possible but
just post all your requests in the
comments below but just a reminder that
Jessica Jones is dropping tonight so be
sure to check some episodes out because
my non-spoilery review will be posting
really soon
click here for brand new infinity war
and click here for my brand new flash
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you